hi everyone I'm Ian so I'll be talking
about a recently published method called
lightweight random indexing it's
basically something that you can use to
combine datasets for text classification
off across multiple languages so this is
just gonna be like a paper presentation
this isn't something that I see very
often mostly what you see these days
around text datasets across multiple
languages is like machine translation or
something this is something separate
from that but we'll compare against it
at the end yeah we'll go over some like
high-level code examples that maybe
oversimplified but you'll get to see
what the method looks like at a really
small scale so here's our agenda we'll
go over what text classification is see
what the vanilla version of random
indexing is and we'll also talk about
random projections and how it differs
from those and then we'll look at
lightweight random indexing and see the
results from the paper but first a
little bit about me I studied at
Michigan State University for graduate
school and undergrad I stuck around to
do research and evolutionary computation
and then after graduating last year I
came to quantum black which is the sort
of advanced analytics arm of McKinsey
Consulting yeah I've worked on lots of
industries and that's I'd love to talk
about it if you want to hear anything
about it yeah so content so what is text
classification hopefully everyone knows
but if you don't this is basically
learning this mapping F from a document
to a particular label or multiple labels
examples would be like labeling what
kind of abuse of toxic comment is giving
applying search terms to scientific
articles or applying news topics to news
articles so this is an example this is a
Rouge news article and then for this
fiat-chrysler is signing some kind of
merger so you would want to apply labels
automotive and business news to this and
basically you're just caring about this
function f but of course most machine
learning models can't just ingest a raw
document so you have to encode them
Oh lots of ways to do this for a bag of
words which is the most simple you just
count occurrences of words tf-idf is a
little more fancy it's like a bag of
words but you get these statistics out
that tell you how important a certain
word is based off of how often it occurs
in a document things like that and then
you also have even fancier word
embeddings like we're Tyvek where you're
mapping words to vector spaces where you
get all those cool results where you
like add two words together and get a
different word that's kind of related to
it yeah so let's see what this looks
like in Python because we are at PI data
if we have this very simple corpus this
is more to just establish a running
example we just instantiate our tf-idf
vectorizer from SK learn fit transform
and then turn it into a back into a
dense matrix because it operates off
sparse matrices by default except the
columns to our feature names and this is
what you get it's what you would expect
the has a very low weight and all the
documents because it occurs in all of
them and those words that are unique to
each document have higher weights yeah
so what happens when our corpus turns
into multiple corpora that are across
multiple different languages yeah so
multi languages datasets present like a
kind of a unique challenge for text
classification it's the same problem
that you're dealing with so in the news
articles example it would just be
multiple news articles across many
different languages but you're trying to
assign the same labels to them and the
documents may not be parallel which
means that they aren't just directly
translations of each other they're going
to be localized in this case journalists
writing in their home language not just
translating things from the English
version which causes problems sometimes
and then yeah so there's lots of ways
that we can tackle this problem so let's
look at some very naive ways first and
then we can look at the the fancier ways
so what if we just concatenated them all
and then filled n A's with zeros this is
probably the simplest and maybe first
approach that we would all think about
this either forces us to create too
large of a document term matrix but if
that's not an issue
maybe we choose too small the vocabulary
for each language so we wouldn't capture
enough information yeah so what else
could we do we could just build a
separate classifier for every language
and then just combine the results this
runs into the problem that every
classifier that you're building now has
less data and you're losing information
around like proper nouns or maybe
cognates that are shared across all of
the languages that mean the same thing
like if we're talking about PI data and
Spanish it still means the same thing
yeah so the approach that we want needs
to be able to use information across all
of these data sets in one data or in one
large data set hopefully get around the
curse of dimensionality and only create
one classifier to capture this sort of
information that we need that is shared
across all of the languages yeah and by
the end of this presentation hopefully
we'll fill in the mystery profits step
and figure out what's how well we can do
this
so first we'll talk about random
indexing to plug the paper really quick
that I'm sort of presenting here it is
you can go look it up it's published in
the Journal of artificial intelligence
research and 2016 most of the notation
that we'll use is there's most of the
explanations I'll use are also there's
yeah and before we go and look at random
indexing we'll look at a very similar
method called random projections which
you may heard of which kind of just
builds like some theoretical support
around like why it sort of makes sense
to do this yeah so like I said random
indexing is closely related to random
projections this is the basic setup for
a random projection basically you have
your data in this huge X matrix and you
have this lambda which is your
projection matrix which Maps the
original M features to some different n
dimensional feature space a lot of times
this n sm is supposed to be greater than
m but
usually this space that you're mapping
to is smaller so you get some kind of
dimensionality reduction but that
doesn't always have to be the case I've
seen cases where it's actually larger
and it's just easier to learn in a
projected space than it is at the
original space yeah so basically at its
most basic this lambda will just be a
completely random matrix that's
obviously not the best way to do it and
there's some rules that you can follow
around making a good projection I will
see those next but first really quickly
maybe this isn't too surprising either
if we have our same corpus our same
tf-idf encoding this is the simplest
random projection you could possibly
think of where you just multiply it by a
completely random normally distributed
matrix and then this new matrix would be
our training data yeah so these two
theoretical results are kind of why
random projections would work the
Johnson Lyndon Strauss says that random
projections approximately preserve
relative distance and maybe these are
like gross oversimplification so if
you're a random projection guru maybe
save it till after the talk and then
this heck Nilsen result that says there
are many more almost orthogonal
directions than there are truly
orthogonal and high dimensional space
and this idea of almost orthogonal
becomes closer and closer to orthogonal
as you get more and more dimensions
basically what these are saying when you
add them up is that your model if it
could tell the difference in full space
it should be able to tell the difference
in this X hat space once it's projected
so if things are far apart they remain
far apart and if they are pointing in
different directions they should remain
pointing in different directions once
you project them yeah it's hard to
visualize this sort of thing because you
need lots of dimensions actually do it
in any useful way but yeah that's the
main idea so when does this go wrong of
course you have to allocate this
potentially very large document term
matrix which is the number of documents
we have by n dimensions which is the
size of our vocabulary that we're
keeping track of
you also have to allocate this
potentially large projection matrix and
then do this cubic operation of
multiplying them together sometimes you
can remove some of this headache of just
using sparse matrices because all of
this data can be sparse your projection
matrix can be sparse your document turn
matrix is sparse for sure but the
alternative method that we'll be looking
at random indexing is supposed to be
getting around these issues of this huge
matrix step as it's called yeah so this
description won't be very clear at the
beginning but of course we have Python
code to look at so instead of doing this
huge matrix multiply
you'll to save time and memory I guess
you'll be assigning every feature in
your vocabulary a random index vector
which is just some vector of length n
with K nonzero values in it
traditionally these cave nonzero values
are just taken from negative 1 and 1 but
different flavors different what indexes
they're choosing and then you just
iterate over your corpus and for each
document you just add up these vectors
so if you encounter the word dog you add
the word the index vector for dog to
your row for that document yeah so you
just accumulate these through your whole
corpus for every document and then at
the end you have this iterative process
rather than this big matrix multiply
that you have to have both matrices in
memory for maybe this will be a little
bit clearer
so we have our corpus again with the
punctuation and lower case everything
taken out and then these are the very
randomly assigned index vectors that I
did by hand and then this is our matrix
that we will be outputting and
accumulating our vectors on so for every
document and our corpus will be adding
the sum of all of its indices 2 to that
row that's the whole algorithm and then
instead of that random projection that
we saw before
or this random index matrix will be our
new training data this is I guess a
quadratic operation rather than a cubic
for doing the random projection so you
should save a little bit of time and it
for sure saves memory because all you
need now is this dictionary and then
this hopefully sparse matrix but I did
numpy so we can all look at it yeah so
what did this actually help like I said
we saved a little bit of memory we don't
need these two big matrices anymore
and we have that quadratic complexity
yeah so why do we talk about random
projections at all it seems kind of
useless random indexing act turns out to
actually approximate a random projection
under certain circumstances it's the way
that you're choosing the nonzero values
in those index vectors at Cleopas in
2001 showed that if you choose your
index vectors carefully you'll be
approximating the Johnson Lyndon Strauss
lemma so that means that when we do the
random indexing from our original data
will pre preserving approximate distance
or relative distance but we haven't
quite done that orthogonality result yet
so how do we get that will be the next
question that we answer which is
hopefully solved by lightweight random
indexing okay a lot going on on this
slide the basic idea is that it takes
lightweight random indexing takes the
sparsity and your index vectors to be
like the most extreme possible which it
sets only two values and the whole index
vector to be nonzero and they're chosen
from the set one over the square root of
negative or whatever the square root of
two that's so that every vector has
length 1 which the authors don't really
talk about why is important but they do
talk about why you only choose two
values to be nonzero and this is
basically maximizing the chance that any
two index vectors will be orthogonal and
out of that result you kind of get an
approximation of the heck Nilsen result
which
will cause our resulting matrix to have
nearly orthogonal vectors as the result
so things that looked different in the
original space will still look different
once we apply random indexing yeah and
then when we're building our final
matrix will also multiply our index
vector by the tf-idf value for any word
this graph other than me just liking it
this is the probability that any two uh
two pairwise random index vectors will
be orthogonal to each other based off of
how many nonzero values they have and
then how long they are on the I guess
the y axis basically this is just saying
that the probability is maximized when
you use one element would be best but
you have to use two elements because if
you just use one you just be randomly
permuting your feature space which is
not super helpful yeah I think that's
the whole thing
so this is Python code to actually build
this dictionary again the same example
that we've been looking at we have our
feature names from our vectorizer
we build this dictionary we'll set our
vectors to have like four two nonzero
elements that are being pulled from this
non zero element set and then for every
word in our vocabulary we'll just choose
the first index deterministically which
is just whatever index that was in the
vocabulary mod how long the vector is
and then the next index will just be
some random index in the vector that
isn't the original one that we picked
and that's it
this is an example resulting index set
you can see that everything is one over
the square root of two as we all know
how to do that in our head right and
it's either positive or negative that
value yeah and then so you just apply
the same thing that we saw before you
just iterate through your corpus and
incrementally add these up to each row
that your documents are corresponding to
and your document to your matrix that's
all algorithm hopefully no one lost
their way we
we're trying to apply this to languages
that are datasets that have multiple
languages and we sort of didn't really
talk about that until right now so what
do we need to do first to apply this in
a useful way what we do first is whine
our documenter matrices or just our
vocabularies if if we're not building
the whole matrix but this is just good
for visualization in this special way
and then project it using lightweight
random indexing so for language one
which is M 1 and M 2 and language -
which is M 3 and M 4 will align them in
this special matrix that has zeros on
the off diagonal and then this common
term matrix down the middle basically
what this does is aligns basically
you're just aligning your proper nouns
and your cognates so you're not losing
that information across languages and
then you just apply my random indexing
to this matrix not too crazy but this is
a little example for just a to document
to language corpus document to matrices
again that we encoded with tf-idf we
lost a few stop words and apostrophes
but that's okay and then we just would
take the terms that are unique to the
English vocab terms that are unique to
the French vocab and then terms that are
common set them to be the middle and
then have all the other non unique terms
or unique terms be on the left on the
right and that's basically the whole
method so you would apply lightweight
random indexing to this matrix and then
train them all on top of it yeah so that
was the whole method like I said let's
look at results from the original paper
so the setup of their experiment was
using this our CV one and two data set
which may be someone who's heard of it's
basically a bunch of
Reuters news articles from like the 90s
this is not from the 90s this is like
last week but yeah they're publicly
available you can get them through NIST
you have to like fill out a form or
something and then you will basically
try to be applying the Reuters news
topics to these datasets or to these
documents the original paper took out
some of the classes because they are too
small and you can go online and get
their training and testing stats if you
want to reproduce their results same
example that we saw from before yep
so the these are some final statistics
on the data that they actually used they
took 8,000 news stories from five
different languages English French
Spanish German and Italian and then
aligned them all like we saw before when
they got about 15,000 common terms
across the entire data set and a total
of 100,000 features so this is a very
under determined data set it's very fat
than very short that's okay though you
just have to regularize yeah and
basically the way that you do this is
you just do all versus one
classification you generate 67 different
classifiers that are performing just a
binary test that says is this class one
or not is it class two or not etc and
then they used micro and macro f1 score
the formula for everyone that forgot it
basically macro f1 computes f1 scores
for each class and then averages them
and then micro f1 computes true and
false positives and false negatives for
each class and that applies the f1
formula macro F 1 is going to be treat
all classes treating all classes as if
they had the same frequency and micro f1
will be waiting classes based off of
their frequencies yeah so this is
basically our pipeline we start with all
of these corpora from different
languages get their tf-idf embedding and
codings align their vocabularies we
don't
to actually align their datasets you
just need to align their vocabularies to
get the common terms across them and
then build your lightweight random
indexing index vectors apply that
algorithm that we saw and then build a
model on top of the new dataset okay and
these are the results for English
classification so the naive classifier
is just trained on tf-idf for only
English this is sort of like the
baseline of that you would think to do
first where you train one classifier on
every single language here in this table
is we're looking at training on all five
languages once you apply the lightweight
random indexing and MT is a machine
translation method where you translate
everything with machine translation into
English and then train one model on top
of it and for lightweight random
indexing the projected dimension is not
reduced so this is more of like a
information encoding task rather than a
dimensionality reduction the authors
give a few interesting examples of why
this might be working a little bit
better than machine translation I'm
saying some some things around
orthogonality when you go from one
language to another you might be yes
terms are different when you're when
you're looking at nouns but it might not
be the case that they're orthogonal to
each other when you align them so when
you apply this lightweight random
indexing where everything is supposed to
be orthogonal to each other the the
place that you're projecting to will
have these terms that may have not been
orthogonal in the original data set we
were talking about in the new data set
yeah so that was a lot of mumbo-jumbo
for the information may be presented in
a more learner bull representation yeah
that's it those special thanks to my
colleagues Luke for introducing the
method to me and Matt and Jody for
encouraging me to come present to you
good people
yeah that's it any questions
[Applause]
yeah so more depth around why it's
outperforming machine translation so
they gave another kind of argument
around why you wouldn't want to use
machine translation and it was around
the original statistical properties of
your data and then the translated
statistical properties of your data
might not match up anymore so this would
be like maybe orthogonality of vectors
but things around like distributions of
word types and things like that they
might change when you apply machine
translation where it might kind of like
muddy those waters and then when you use
this method that's just very hard line
forcing everything to be orthogonal it
might just be a little more learn about
that that makes sense